one
Aya and I will present to you skin
microbiome Solutions based on psoriasis
studies
now what is the problem with psoriasis
psoriasis is a chronic inflammatory skin
disease it affects 125 million people
worldwide of any age gender or arrays it
has unknown causes and has no cure the
resume is practically trial and error
and it is a difficult disease to manage
why skin microbiome metagenomics well
since the microbial population psoriasis
patients produces inflammatory molecules
and virus to bodyside it is important to
study the individual microbial profile
to understand the disease better
personalized treatment based on
individuals microbial profile will offer
solutions that can improve their
patient's symptoms lower the risk to
develop psoriatric arthritis and reduce
their economic burden
we studied then the microbiome of
psoriasis data set that's publicly
available we compare the microbial
diversity and abundance of the health
control group and the psoriasis group
and what we found is that we see
some bacterial species that are
specifically present in both groups but
mainly that there are detected species
that are only present in one or the
other groups we in general see a
diversity between the uh the health the
control healthy group and the psoriasis
group
that leads us to a couple of conclusions
firstly that the skin of absorias
patients is has more pathogenic microbes
and less conventional microbes and it
it's different between skin sites the
disease also requires a more long-term
management
the first three conclusions leads us to
potentially a solution that is focused
on bacterial therapy such as probiotic
creams
the second the fourth conclusion leads
us to a potentially monitoring the
disease through an app
that can monitor the cycles of the
disease
how would it work practically we take a
sample of um of your skin then we
provide to you with a skin psoriasis
skin microbiome profile where it's the
patient and
talks with a dermatologist and um and
are given a specific
uh profile and cream for the skin side
that they have
finally you continue the treatment and
monitor it through the app
now what is important about a probiotic
bacteriotherapy creams is that uh
our goal is to create a set of probiotic
creams that would be customized to the
skin microbiome of the skin sides of the
patient
Studies have shown that certain microbes
can increase the immune response or
decrease the abundance of pathogenic
backgrounds that's why I'm bacterial
therapy creams would be effective in
this case
and the advantages are that it is a
solution that is customized to the
patient it can be used as a
complementary solution to
anti-inflammatory treatments to steroids
it's not invasive and not painful
the other solution is a mobile app
current mobile applications for
psoriasis offer monitoring of the
disease or network we focus on
monitoring if the patient practically
takes a picture of the skin notes of the
flares and the intensity and communicate
with the dermatologists through the app
about potential
reviewing their data what we add to with
our solution would be to provide a skin
microbiome profile of the patient which
can become potentially machine learning
technology
uh provided with updated research
information related to the microbiome
profile and the customized list of
products that can be known to help with
their profile eventually a guard
microbiome profiler would be added to
this product
um the way we see it ahead is firstly to
do an extensive study of the of
psoriasis skin microbiota profiles to
actually detect the profiles then
collaborate with dermatologists to find
patients that have to that are connected
with the proposition we could figure out
what kind of print would work for them
specifically what probiotic would work
for them time like create a timeline for
the application development and identify
the formulas that would work for the
specific patients and the profiles that
we have found
and then collaborate with
Pharmaceuticals to start producing them
and start the first trials launch the
beta versions and come to investors
within my product to Market
thank you very much for your attention I
hope you have a great day ahead